Stove Top Stuffing slap why do we only
allow ourselves to eat it one day of the
year that I'm an adult and I want
stuffing when I want it so let me show
you how to turn this box of breadcrumbs
and some salt into a full meal that you
can eat all year round yes for protein
we got turkey sausage fiber we got some
veg fruit and some
herbs healthy fats we've got some
nuts
oo she's a
be throw our little hunger crushion
combo mixture into the
stuffing all right we got this a tidy
factor from our hunger crushing
compounds and the satisfaction factor
with different colors flavors and
textures this is how we make Stove Top
Stuffing an everyday
meal to good